alexei has to learn to stand on two feet
again
originally from belarus he's been part
of the ukrainian army off and on for
about eight years
now the war has taken its toll
two weeks after the fighting started he
was on a reconnaissance patrol when a
russian shell struck nearby
now he's learning to walk on an
artificial leg
two or three weeks ago i still needed
two crutches not like this one but real
crutches that you wedge under your arms
now i manage without
i use this one like a cane
now alexei trains recruits
so many belarusians have joined
ukraine's armed forces since the war
started that they formed an entire
regiment of their own
alexei came to ukraine in 2014 after
kiev's euro maidan protests
crane is one of the last free countries
remaining of the former soviet republics
if it had lost its freedom if the maidan
protests had been put down
there would have been no future left for
the region
neither for ukraine nor for belarus
now the belarusian regiment numbers
several hundred troops
many of them fled to ukraine in 2020
after president alexander lukashenko
crushed mass protests all across belarus
rosker as his fellow troopers call him
is part of the regiment he also took
part in the protests in belarus
we were hoping we could topple
lukashenko peacefully
but unfortunately
our hopes did not come true
and the regime is still in power
my task now is to do everything i can to
bring down this regime
to the soldiers of the belarusian
regiment the ukrainians fight is also
very much theirs
they can't go back to their country now
anyway
i could expect a life sentence at the
very least and at the worst execution
for my participation in the protests
they could charge me with extremism
and now on top of that with being a
mercenary in the war
[Music]
the fighters have many different
political opinions
what unites them is their opposition to
the regime in belarus
in 2014 alexei first joined the
right-wing nationalist azov battalion
since february he's been with the
belarusian regiment
he describes himself as a nationalist
nationalists want to live in a free
country
the form it takes
whether democracy or something else
is not so important
the main thing is that people can choose
and develop as they wish at the moment
there's no development in belarus
now alexei's morning starts with
physiotherapy
his body has to learn to keep its
balance without help from the left leg
he's down to receive a new
electronically controlled prosthesis
eventually
if alexei had his way he'd like to go
back to the front
i won't be able to return to active duty
like i used to
but there are many different jobs at the
front
different kinds of weapons
but i won't be able to fight in my
former unit
that's physically no longer
possible for the time being it's
training training and more training he
still has many steps to take before he
can return to the front
you